martin va faire une randonnée de
motoneige avec juliette sa fille de 17
ans policiers les arrêtent et leur
demander leurs papiers martin présente
sur permis les certificats
d'immatriculation et une attestation
d'assurance juliette elle présente
fièrement son permis de conduire mais le
policier leur annonce qu'elle
contrevient à la loi il donne même une
amende de 100 $ à julien quentel fait de
cigares l'agent de police leur explique
qu'on peut conduire une motoneige à
partir de 16 mai les jeunes âgées de
saint vith s'étend comme juliette
doivent obtenir un certificat d'aptitude
pour conduire une motoneige pour
n'obtenir juliette aurait dû suivre une
formation théorique de quelques heures
offertes par une école de conduite
autorisée et oui à 16 et 17 ans le
permis de conduire ne suffit pas pour
circuler à moto neige et ignorer ces
règles coûte très cher juliette a eu une
amende de 100 dollars mais ce n'est pas
tout malgré son père a aussi reçu une
amende salée que 550 $ + livres pour
avoir permis à sa fille de conduire sans
certificat le fin mot de l'histoire
avant de partir à l'aventuré avec vos
enfants mettez la [ __ ] douce prenez le
temps de connaître les rênes